we are producing a lot more data than
we're capable of storing today we think
that to put a dent on the problem we
need a radical new solution and so we're
looking at DNA as one such solution and
one of the reasons that we're using DNA
it's density is orders of magnitude
higher than anything that exists today
its reliability and resiliency and then
it is has relevancy we think that as
long as there are humans alive we'll
care about reading our own DNA that
means that we'll have a storage format
that will be with us that will always be
relevant we have been working on using
DNA for data storage for several years
now and but the process so far has been
credibly manual literally people moving
around with pipettes in their hands so
in the only way we're gonna make DNA
data storage scale up to be usable and
be you know go mainstream is by
automating it and what we've done with
this with the project that you can learn
more about now is showing that it's
possible to automate the entire process
from bits to molecules and back to two
bits the writing process takes your data
file and encodes those ones and zeros
into a C's T's and G's those a C's T's
and G's are actually what gets sent to
the device itself every base that flows
into the column incorporates itself onto
a strand of DNA so once all the DNA
bases have been incorporated into the
strands on the column these strands need
to be removed from the column so we pump
a chemical mixture into the column which
frees them from their solid support and
pushes them into a liquid storage bottle
so once we decide to read the data off
the DNA the read master mix is applied
to the DNA storage pool that master mix
prepares the DNA to be read
now that the DNA is readable it gets
pumped into the read device where it
gets translated into a C's T's and G's
sequences the computer can understand
those sequences then get decoded back
into ones and zeros moving into the
future what we'd like to do is move
fluids around in a more intelligent way
which is accomplished by the purple drop
project so we're basically making the
like biological primitives moving and
mixing droplets accessible like software
is today because you can just compose it
as much as you want so you can start
with simple systems and then you can
build it up and to like it automatic
experimentation machine basically what
you're doing is because water is
polarizable you can generate a charge in
it and so by changing the charge on the
board in different locations you can
attract the water to those locations I
think what the other thing is
interesting to realize about this result
too is that this might be pointing to a
new kind of computer system that has an
electronic components and a molecular
component so use molecules for what
you're good at use electronics for
they're good at and then you integrate
them and show that it's actually
possible to good a system that has dry
electronics wet molecules and they
together do something amazing
Microsoft has seen this impending crisis
of not being able to store information
as we move forward
and invest in a technology that could
revolutionize the way that we think
about data storage